there's a new york police captain named
Peter rose who said he was not too
worried about a sixty-two percent
increase in rapes in Greenpoint Brooklyn
because most of the rapes weren't
committed by strangers here is a quote
from Captain Peter Rose every rape
should be investigated I wish we could
do more it really becomes a balancing
act for the investigators some of them
were tender some of them were hookup
sites some of them were actually
co-workers it's not a trend that we're
worried about because out of 13 sex
attacks only two were true stranger
rapes if there's a true stranger rape a
random guy picks up a stranger off the
street those are the troubling ones that
person has like no moral standards now
some people say there's no such thing as
marital or in a relationship rape that
the concept doesn't compute the law
doesn't agree let's put that aside for a
second since that's not most people's
belief the reality is that most rape is
current or former partners or
acquaintances that are known to the
victims according to a 2012 report from
the National centers for disease control
only around fourteen percent of rapes
are committed by strangers so of course
the NYPD went into damage control mode
they apologized for what Peter Rose said
they said that they take all complaints
of rape and sexual assault seriously no
matter who the alleged perpetrator is
etcetera etcetera but this does expose
what we already knew to be an underlying
attitude about rape and sexual assault
by the way of the 13 rapes in greenpoint
last year but two of the thirteen were
strangers ten of the thirteen remain
unsolved so think about those numbers
for a second now some people will hear
us talking about this patent will say
David with the police officer is saying
is that you can talk about basic safety
measures that people can take to not be
as as at much at risk for stranger rape
right you don't want to be alone in
certain places at certain times of day
you want to be above generally aware
when you're taking public transit for
example so I understand what's being
said but there's another way to express
that without saying that an increase in
stranger rape isn't concerning there
certainly is a different strategy in
terms of dealing with rapes among
strangers and within groups of people
that know each other yeah and they have
to be treated differently I would say
but I think I think he really just word
of this inarticulately there's a case to
be made if we are playing the what is
more shocking and traumatic game which
is in a game I care to play but it seems
captain Peter Rose maybe was playing it
you could argue that rape or sexual
assault by people you know is in a sense
more traumatic insofar as even among
people you know you may not be safe and
that is a horrible horrible thing to
feel from a police perspective both of
them are just as awful someone was raped
in a terrible crime was committed in the
first case the victim can be put into
maybe protective custody you can locate
the assailant and arrest them quickly in
the second case from a police
perspective you've got maybe a rapist on
the loose potentially a serial rapist on
the loose until you capture them but i
agree with pat inarticulately said is
the most charitable way to approach this
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the David Pakman
show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated